Until we open our mouths and speak...
...exposing our personality to those around us,...
...the only thing they have to go by to make an opinion about us...
...is our physical body and appearance.
Though it goes without saying that our minds are the most important part of us,...
...our physical selves are also important and should be attended to.
Just as we should always strive to improve our minds through education,...
...we should strive to improve our fitness through physical training.
Once you decide to exercise,...
...you must then settle on a style.
Are you going to weight train, or focus on cardiovascular health?
I myself have decided to go with both.
I do a mixture of free weights and machine weights...
...and outside jogging and cardio machines.
Once I feel that I'm in good enough shape,...
...I've chosen to do some Yoga as well...
...probably in the morning.
It will warm me up for the day's exercise...
...whether it is weight training or cardio.
What is your plan?